what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time while
whilst you're trying to get rich
russell's trying to get our lunch money
right i'm here with the beautiful
intelligent basically perfect palina
evilova marinova pompliano p-i-m-p
don't forget that lunch money is now
sponsored by block five block five has
three products you can buy and sell
crypto might be a good time to start
looking at crypto you can earn up to
eight point six percent apy
in an interest-bearing account or you
can take out a us dollar loan and get
your crypto collateral go get a block fi
account
blockfy.com pomp again blockfi.com
i'm an investor i'm a user i'm a very
happy user go check them out wifi.com
also huge shout out to candice stevens
who is a lunch money viewer
with her son i really appreciate you and
it makes my day that you watch
okay let's go bitcoin broke through
record highs clearing a major milestone
above 20
000 only to trade at 23 000 today is
that right
over 23 000. so there's chief
market technician named jc o'hara
at mkm partners who called the record
rally at the beginning of november now
he sees a breakout that's only in the
early
innings he thinks that bitcoin
bitcoin's next stop will take it above
25 000.
mkm everyone's gonna come out the
woodwork now saying they called [ __ ]
everyone well you did you no no you
can't show up in november and be like i
called it
it's over 23 000. my favorite part i was
telling plenty this last night we were
out for a walk
and i said uh there's people that i've
met over the last four or five years
that
uh absolutely i'm happiest for them
these are the people who they're
construction workers uh
they live it somewhere in eastern europe
uh they're in south america
they're in nigeria all these different
places
or they're here in america in north
america and
they work kind of everyday jobs and
what's happened is
they had an opportunity they educated
themselves and they took action
and they were able to build as part of a
portfolio they were able to build
uh some exposure to bitcoin and when
they did that
they're benefiting from it and some of
them have performed
better than what the best hedge fund
managers and
yeah if you just held bitcoin for uh
you know five years then you've
outperformed almost every hedge fund on
wall street that's wild
so the everyday people the people on
lunch money street
are the best investors okay i love it i
love it all right next
congressional leaders closed in on a 900
billion dollar coronavirus relief deal
as millions of
struggling americans wait for help the
developing aid agreement would not
include liability protections for
businesses or aid to state and local
government
900 billion 700 billion a trillion
2 trillion 500 billion what's a couple
hundred billion between friends
nothing so you've been getting good that
was pretty good
uh by the way i see you brought your
guns today guys i've been working oh
look at my gun okay
uh and so look there's obviously people
need help um
the number one way to solve the problem
is open up the economies keep the old
uh and the sick and those who are scared
at home help them
and let everyone else go back to work
and now we have better testing more
accessibility to testing so
i mean if i'm sorry and there's a
vaccine if the nba can test
themselves every day and play these
sweaty games
i think we can do a better job with the
regular
humans
[Music]
and when you see the photos of what
they've been doing for the last couple
of months
you're going to wonder why in the united
states or are we doing that so i
actually read this really interesting
article how people
there's like a dark tourist economy
where people
like to travel to ground zero like where
really tragic things have happened which
is really strange
but like a lot of people came to new
york after 9 11. a lot of people are
going to wuhan
china after kovid although it's not over
yet guys when i hear wuhan china i think
wu tang
go ahead shout out jason williams go
ahead facebook accused rival
apple of engaging in anti-competitive
practices
firing another shot in a months-long
standoff between the two tech giants
over apple's planned privacy changes
for ios 14. so here's what facebook uh
vp of ads and business products dan levy
said
um apple is behaving anti-competitively
by using their control of the app store
to benefit their bottom line at the
expense of creators
in small businesses full stop you know
somebody serious when they end the
sentence with
full stop so in response apple said that
its new rules will not require facebook
to change its
approach to tracking users and creating
targeted advertising
but instead requires facebook to give
users on apple devices a choice
of whether to opt into those practices
what do you think about that
haven't worked at facebook i know dan
levy i
used to work with him he's fantastic
he's probably one of the smartest
kindest
smartest people full stop no he's just
an awesome guy
awesome guy uh so shout out to dan um
look
facebook is uh under a lot of pressure
right now from regulators
and uh one of the things that you could
do
to maybe highlight that this isn't a
facebook thing this is just
how technology competition works is
begin highlighting all the
anti-competitive practices of everybody
else
right and uh i think that it is
actually got a lot of teeth to it by the
way wait what has teeth the apple
claim or the apple claim but by the way
so does everyone else against facebook
like of course that's the point of
business you don't want to compete with
people
so of course you're trying to do things
to hurt your competitors and try to win
like all of a sudden we're all acting
like uh there's some other uh way to
build a business like of course you're
competing you're trying not to let your
competitors win
duh and so i think that what's happening
here is
we're gonna start to find out in this
new technology uh world
this digital world where's the line
right where do regulators and courts
think the line is
i don't know nobody else knows until the
courts decide so we're gonna find out
but nobody should be surprised that all
of these tech giants are all
anti-competitive with each other
duh that's the whole point of
competition is to not let your
competitors succeed
right so if you guys scroll
back to many many moons ago when we did
a lunch money
you will remember that luck and coffee
in china was facing some major fraud
situation accusations charges whatever
so now
china's embattled coffee delivery
startup look in has reached a settlement
with the us
sec agreeing to pay a hundred and eighty
million dollar penalty to settle charges
that it overstated its revenues expenses
and losses by the hundreds of millions
of dollars
do you remember when they were like oh
we don't have like a cfo what was that
we can't find the money find the money
or something
yeah of course every front wire card
luck in whatever uh
shout out carson block from muddy waters
he did it muddy waters is
probably one of the best uh short
sellers in the world
um they're kind of a research they go in
they find it they put together a report
they take a short position and they come
out and they say hey i've got a short
position on this company here's why can
you explain how like short sellers do
their research
how do they get in the company and look
at the books i mean they can talk to
people they can find uh filings they can
say oh lucken says that they're
uh serving you know six million cups of
coffee a day
cool who are there uh who are the people
who provide the manufacturing for the
cups who are the people who
provide them with the coffee beans for
example okay i'm gonna go talk to those
companies that companies like
we're not selling them enough cups to be
selling six million cups a day
so we're selling them enough where they
can be selling a hundred thousand i'm
making all this
it's all hypothetical he's like oh
that's an important red flag that your
vendor says that they're not even
selling you enough cups for the coffee
to go in for you to sell that much
and so stuff like that is how they
basically investigative journalism in a
way
yes the only difference is that the
journalist publishes an article and the
short sellers get rich
cool both are fixed yeah they're both
important but i'm just saying
all right prince harry and meghan markle
are the latest to strike a deal with
spotify um
they're gonna produce okay so they've
teamed up with spotify to produce and
host podcasts through their newly formed
audio production company
archie well audio their son's name is
archie
the multi-year partnership will allow
the couple to establish themselves
in the growing market of podcasting
meghan markle just
uh made uh in her first startup tech
investment
i have a feeling they're gonna become
they're living in l.a they're gonna
become like the tech
podcast power couple that's my
my theory who are they
oh come on they're unemployed so the
couple's first offering will be a
holiday special hosted by themselves
that will feature stories of hope and
compassion from inspirational guests in
celebration of the new year
oh i wonder if serena will be on there
she's like best friends with meghan
markle
throughout 2021 the couple will continue
producing content through the
partnership that will build community
through shared experiences and values
why do you think they're doing it i i
doubt they need the money but maybe
he's cut off from the royal family now
so
oh okay i'm not good i mean no he just
has to make money like i don't
i don't actually know what i think he's
doing just fine okay
i think he's doing just fine so do you
think they like are gonna move out of
california
they better next thing you know they're
being run by dictators meghan markle and
prince harry moved to austin texas if
you live in if you live in california
right now i would love to know i would
love to know why you still live there
please leave a comment okay
please leave a comment and just tell us
why i just i'm fascinated by the logic
as to why somebody would still live in a
state where they take most of your money
or a lot of your money and they are
super upset somebody commented on the
last lunch money and asked why
we still live in new york is the same
thing how do you know i still live in
new york
this ain't new york okay um okay so are
we
are we on to ask lunch money time
by the way polina just exit out of that
tab and then also that's a holiday
holiday gift type did i give oh no we
don't need any
more online it's a holiday gift guide
for the curious minds
that's what i'm looking at all right ask
lm in the comments below give me some
good ones give me some meaty ones and
self
just asking him questions i'm here too
guys okay
oh shoot
she didn't get them she didn't get it
but i thought that's content
that's why nobody asks you questions is
because you can't find the questions
okay i'll ask one from yesterday that i
didn't get to ask
dylan you guys are awesome with great
content pompeo to man and pimp you to
gal congrats on the tomato plant
thank you dylan do you know how many
tomatoes were the tomatoes good
were the tomatoes good they were good
question is about private company
investing i can appreciate that the best
opportunities come through connections
but what are your thoughts on private
company investing platforms such as seed
invest microventure
start engine also what about collectible
investing platforms like rally and
collectible
appreciate you both and have a great and
safe holiday you go first
oh what um i i will
i will pass on this
[Laughter]
uh look investing in private companies
obviously is great
um i am less bullish on
those kind of crowdfunding type
platforms just because they're selection
bias
so the absolute best deals don't go on
them normally uh every once in a while
what they'll do is they'll raise from
like tier one investors i had a company
do this
uh where they race from a bunch of tier
ones first round capital etc and then
they opened up a
very very small round for kind of
accredited investors that are outside of
silicon valley
um if you can find a deal where there's
tier one investors you're co-investing
alongside them on the same terms
okay that's interesting but pretty much
all the other deals on there there's a
lot of selection bias
and i think you're better off probably
just refraining from
investing there's a reason why the best
investors in the world do it full time
there's a reason why
they've been able to accumulate a lot of
capital uh to invest they're good at
what they do
right and so i think that that's kind of
one of the key pieces to this uh the
second thing i would say is around the
collectible stuff whether it's rally
goat uh collectible i mean there's a
bunch of these um
my personal favorite is rally i know
some of the guys over there they're
awesome uh really really big fan of them
um
and i think it's interesting like if you
can basically get a fractional share
of a collectible car or a really
expensive uh trading card or whatever
again do your research if you understand
that stuff
sure you can make money um you can also
use like masterworks you can buy
fractional shares and really expensive
art so if you know about art go do that
um i tend to just think that like this
should be a smaller part of your
portfolio right not investment advice
but just
if i don't know if you necessarily want
majority of your portfolio to be
uh you know part of um these uh
collectible platforms but
we'll see and so uh let's see what
happens but i would just say
that uh you should educate yourself and
make sure that you know exactly what
you're doing if you're gonna go play on
these platforms and i would lean more
towards collectibles than private
investing
i would lean the same way if i was to
lean
see ya bang bang hope you guys enjoyed
this episode of lunch money as much as
we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block fight
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind paulina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to eight point six
percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account go do your own research there's
risk associated but eight point six
percent is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends